what's going on Wolfgang I have watched
Avengers infinity war about 15 times
since it's come out on digital release
and of course it is coming out on
blu-ray and 4k very soon if you haven't
had a chance to get your hands on the
digital copy or if you're waiting for
the blu-ray and 4k to come out I will be
giving away a few copies of Avengers
infinity war on blu-ray once it comes
out all you have to do to enter the
giveaway is be subscribed to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your favorite superhero if you would
like to increase your chances of winning
one winner I will be picking directly
from Instagram or Twitter so follow me
on social media if you want to increase
your chances of winning so there's a
question out there that has been buzzing
around for a while now that we finally
got the answer to and that is why did
Thanos wait so long to collect the
Infinity stones let me explain since the
first Avengers movie in 2012 we found
out that Thanos is out to collect all
the Infinity stones but he starts out by
sending other people out to collect them
for him in the very first Avengers movie
in 2012 he gives Loki the sceptre that
has the mine stone in it this is so Loki
can retrieve the tesseract which is the
space stone the deal was that Loki would
use the tesseract to open a portal to
Thanos his army that is waiting for him
in space the Chitauri would come in and
then ultimately help Loki take over and
then become king of the earth after Loki
became king of the earth he would then
hand back the sceptre which had the mine
stone in it and the tesseract which is
the space stone back to Thanos giving
Thanos two Infinity stones
still working on believing but that
didn't really work out for him thanks to
the Avengers and then Thanos was all of
a sudden left with zero Infinity stones
he then sent Ronan out to get the Power
Stone for him but as soon as Ronan found
out what it was kept it for himself
you may have celestial blood do you have
moves like this dance-off bro ultimately
the guardians of the galaxy would end up
defeating Ronan and then they gave the
power stone to the Nova Corps for
safekeeping me versus you it's all
then after the post-credits scene in
Avengers age of Ultron we see Thea no
stick his hand inside the Infinity
Gauntlet and say fine I'll do it myself
and then in Avengers infinity war we see
fan OHS himself go after all the stones
successfully collect them all and
complete his snap so why did Thanos send
other people to get the stones and wait
so long himself to collect them what we
finally have an official answer thanks
to Stephen McFeely and Joe Russo's
commentary on Avengers infinity war and
the answer was he waited until he
captured nebula in reality what he
really waited for was he waited until he
knew where all of the Infinity stones
were once he captured nebula he knew
that Gamora knew where the soul stone
was Thanos did not know where the soul
stone was so he was waiting until he
found the location for each Infinity
stone so he waited to go after the
stones until he knew where each of them
were because according to Joe Russo the
minute he goes after them the forces of
the universe are gonna line up against
him if he doesn't know where the soul
stone is then what is the point this
makes a lot of sense because why go
through a continuous battle against the
forces of the universe if you don't even
know where all the stones are that
battle would go on for a while and now
all of a sudden you have to go against
all of these forces and figure out where
the last stone is so there's the answer
to why Fanus waited so long to go after
the Infinity stones himself but I think
this answer actually raises even more
important questions for me when I hear
this answer I think well who are the
forces he could be talking about the
Avengers but I don't think so this is
Stannis we're talking about here sure
the humans of Earth are stronger than
they anticipated but this is the
immortal mad Titan Thanos he has taken
over world after world after world I
don't think he's worried about humans
what I do think he's worried about is
other super strong beans such as Odin or
ego is it a coincidence that we don't
see fan OHS himself go after all of the
stones until Odin and ego are gone kind
of makes you think does
or is he worried about other beings such
as the Eternals or the cosmic beans is
it a possibility that they could show up
in Avengers 4 I personally think so
they've already said that they are
adding new characters in Avengers 4 that
we haven't seen yet they've only been
seen in the comics so I think it is very
possible that we could see some very
very strong characters and Avengers 4
but what do you all think what do you
think about the recent Ana's waited to
collect all the Infinity stones and do
you think there is some extremely
powerful being out there that we may see
in Avengers 4 let me know your thoughts
in the comments below and again don't
forget about the giveaway all you have
to do to enter is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your favorite superhero thank
you so much for watching woof woof
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]